the chicken is crispy and crunchy
the waffle is like a cloud that soaks up
all the pear butter
hey i'm raeshawn wilder the creator of
eyes of a foodie
and today we'll be making my peanut
butter chicken and waffles my friend
takia from tasty is going to show you
how to make my signature dish
pear butter adds a classy and elegant
touch to my chicken and waffles
start by adding diced pears and water to
a saucepan
then we'll add our nutmeg cinnamon
cloves and allspice
what a lot of people don't know is that
i'm a flight attendant by day
i've seen a lot of different places been
to a lot of different restaurants which
allowed me to expand my brand as a food
blogger
what's up guys this is isabel foodie and
today i am doing some burgers
in 2017 one of my co-workers told me
that i should audition for masterchef
so i flew to new york city and there
were hundreds of
people there to audition i knew that i
had some competition before me
and to be honest i didn't even make it
past the first round
i went back home to detroit and went
back to work
in october of 2018 masterchef was having
auditions again
this time it was the final round of
auditions
and of course my same co-worker told me
that i should audition again
i had no intentions on going back after
what happened in new york the first year
i finally gave in i had decided to make
a cheesecake
but my oven went out and the flights to
dallas were completely oversold
however i finally made it when the
judges tasted my cookie butter
cheesecake
everyone went crazy and i'm proud to say
that out of 20 000 people who auditioned
i made it to the top 80 cast of master
chef season 10.
once i got eliminated i returned home
and i decided to work on my cheesecakes
if my cheesecakes could wow the judges
are masterchef
and lammy in the top 80. i knew that the
people of detroit would also love them
my cookie butter cheesecake is the one
that made a name for me
since then i've created over 25
different flavors including
strawberry shortcake lemon drop orange
cream dream
and my favorite white chocolate
blueberry crumble
now you may be wondering why i'm showing
you how to make chicken waffles today
well the short answer is if i give you
my money making cheesecake recipe
i'd be out of business having my own
business
is really awesome but what good would it
be if i couldn't help other people
my goal as a chef is to inspire other
young african-american men
i really want to help break the
stereotypes of how the world looks at us
with all that's going on in the world
today with police brutality
protests and the black lives matter
movement i know it can be easy for
people of color to be discouraged or
even negative
but i want to encourage all of us that
we have so much to offer to this world
and it's important that we don't allow
the hurdles that we face or what we see
on the news or what we hear in the media
discourage us from reaching our goals my
food journey hasn't been easy by far
i've been eliminated twice and even
doubt tried to creep in sometimes
but i never allowed those things to
hinder me from trying
i had to encourage myself daily and i
want to encourage everyone to use that
same energy towards anything that you're
passionate about
whether that's food or fighting for what
you believe in
but in the meantime love yourself and
love others
try to find the joy in the little things
i hope my pear butter chicken and
waffles recipe
can help bring a little joy into your
life the waffles are super soft and
crispy
the pear butter had the right amount of
sweetness the chicken
perfectly fried i'm telling you you
can't go wrong with this dish
oh yes
you